this is jocko podcast number 305 with
echo charles and me jacqueline willink
good evening echo good evening also
joining us again tonight dave burke good
evening dave
we are going to continue the review of
the book the psychology of military
incompetence which we started on podcast
303 continued 304 we're going to
continue it more now
and we got through
some examples in the last podcast some
of the wartime examples we'll get
through the rest of these examples
tonight
and
this is a big setup
this is a this is an arduous setup for
part two of the book
i don't know if we'll get
into part two of the book tonight
which actually starts to dive into the
psychology of military incompetence
but like i said before
those explorations
continuously refer back to the examples
from the beginning part one of this book
which is what makes the book
powerful
because it's not just theory it gives
you examples that connects the theory to
reality
so that's what we're doing
um if you haven't ordered this book
order it it's called on the psychology
of military incompetence written by dr
dixon
who is a combat vet himself if you
haven't listened to podcast 303 and 304
yet and go back and listen to those
first
we're going through these military
examples and we're starting you can see
them starting to tune in starting to
call out some of these psychological
pathology that ends up with bad
leadership
and with that we're going to go into the
book
this chapter is called between war so we
end
we end
world war
one and this chapter is called between
the wars because what should be
happening between the wars what should
we be doing we should be
assessing what we did wrong assessing
what we did right seeing what
improvements we could make seeing what
new technology we could bring to bear
and let's face it you fight a war like
world war one and there should be
an insane amount of lessons learned
unfortunately this quote starts off with
this book this chapter starts off with a
quote from george bernard shaw and he
says the british soldier can stand up to
anything except the british war office
what a
horrible statement that is
um
going to the book military stock is
never lower than at the end of a costly
war
with a million dead
society's appetite for aggression has
been assuaged people were wary of the
war and tired of soldiering for the
military the truth was rubbed in by
swinging cuts in men and materiel
we're done world war one's done you only
think about being over it they're over
it
from being the most important members of
the community they were now relegated to
a very minor role that's the military
this thinly veiled in gratitude had
three effects upon the military with the
horse yet self-consoling cry
now we can get back to some real
soldiering
they withdrew into cocoons of
professional impotence
and that's strange you get done with the
war you say all right now we can get
back to
soldiering
which for them what does that mean in
accordance with the principle that more
floored aspects of militarism are
defenses against threat to self-esteem
there was a falling back upon the rights
of the barrack square
renewed attention to spit and polish
helped to expunge the last traces of the
mud of flanders
at higher levels of military hierarchy
service thinking was now embodied in an
extract from a paper on imperial defense
dated june 22 1926
quote the size of the forces of the
crown maintained by great britain is
governed by various conditions peculiar
to each service and is not arrived at by
any calculations of the requirements of
foreign policy nor is it possible that
they should ever be so calculated
that's the most insane thing i've read
in quite some time well i guess since i
read the last chapter of this book
hey we're just gonna
the the we're building our military the
size of our military is just based on
kind of what they think it should be had
nothing to do with what's going on
foreign policy
no calculations that's not what we're
doing the period between the wars the
shape and the equipment if not the size
of the armed forces were partly
determined by a number of curious
military attitudes these centered
peculiar procure particularly around
three instruments of warfare tanks
planes and horses
describing a tank attack which he had
witnessed in 1916
general sir richard gail tells how the
british command tried to exploit it with
cavalry apparently they failed as it was
borne out by the grim site of riderless
horses returning once they had come
man that's an eerie image isn't it
of this experience he writes i was
impressed by the potential of the tank
as i was unimpressed by the employment
of horsed cavalry in modern warfare
conditions yet after all our experience
in that war it took us further 20 years
to mechanize our cavalry
the lesson was clear but the lesson was
as clear in 1916 as in 1936. in truth it
was not 1936 but 1941
before the british began to implement
lessons of 1916.
what happened between these wars
shows the alarming extent to which
reactionary elements can draw the wrong
conclusion from what to most people
would seem quite unambiguous facts
rather than recognize the potential of
the tank they drew the conclusion that
innovation and progress are inherently
dangerous and therefore to be eschewed
the symptom is not without precedent nor
confined to the army while on naval
maneuvers in 1893
admiral tryon
wished to about face two parallel
columns of battleships
from his flagship he ordered that the
two columns should reverse course by
turning inwards
unfortunately
the combined turning radius of the ships
was greater than the distance between
them
with mathematical inevitability hms
victoria was rammed by hms camper down
and sank with great loss of life
other officers had seen what was going
to happen but dared not question
the lesson from this disaster seemed
fairly clear admirals should base their
decisions upon information supplied by
their staffs and junior officers should
not be afraid of speaking up when their
knowledge
for example the turning cir turning
circles of naval craft and their special
abilities for example superior eyesight
in greater capacity for mental
arithmetic led them to believe that a
given order would end in calamity
the argument seems sound enough
indeed even the
most junior char lady
which is a cleaning woman at the
admiralty
had she pondered the facts could hardly
have failed to draw the same conclusion
but this was not the conclusion reached
by her lords and masters for them
tryon's lapse just went to show that it
never pays to try anything new there was
the lesson learned
don't do inward don't do that's the
lesson learned don't do inward turns in
a column
to return to the tank the successive
chiefs of the imperial general staff
between 1918 and 1932 39 with the
support of other senior officers did not
exert themselves to mechanize the army
some were actively obstructionist
against these reactionary elements stood
a handful of progressive army officers
and a few like-minded civilians the
progressives who had assimilated
the incontr incontrovertible evidence
from the preceding war with germany and
were only too well aware of hitler's
preparations for the next made their
views known through books essays
lectures and by word of mouth
these moves were countered by the
military establishment in two ways so
you got this whole group of people that
are saying hey bro
and bros
we need to make tanks a lot of them we
need to mechanize our cavalry look what
happened
and that's what they're doing books word
of mouth lectures essays
these moves were countered by the
military establishment two ways firstly
they resisted the dissemination of
progressive literature
hey stifle that paper secondly they did
their best to curtail the careers of
those who questioned their own obsolete
ideas
that's like that's like evil
as far as i'm concerned
guys got a good new idea
curtail their career
for example
when fuller an early protagonist of
mechanization won the rusi gold medal
for his essay on tanks and later
produced a book on the same topic
he was castigated by successive chiefs
of staff and remained unemployed in the
rank of manger general for three years
and then was forcibly retired in 1933
in the course of these events
c-i-c-i-g-s
lord
cavan whose ideas according to fuller
were about 800 years out of date opined
that no officer should be allowed to
write a book
it's like insane you can't make this up
you can't make this up
if you're ever in a situation where your
subordinates are coming up with ideas
that you don't agree with and your your
reaction is to shut them down
question yourself
not to be outdone his successor field
marshall montgomery delivered himself of
a diatribe against fuller's books while
admitting that he had never read them
because it would make him so angry if he
did
equally unambiguous was the treatment
meted out to liedell heart a man
described by the press as quote the most
important military thinker of the age of
mechanization in any country
this is the guy that we covered on the
podcast
i don't know how many episodes we did
but it's
a lot of them
b b.h liddell hart over the years
liddell hart produced a number of
articles and books on mechanization on
new infantry tactics and on the
strategic and tactical use of armor his
efforts encountered extreme hostility
and resistance from the british general
staff
when he submitted his essay
mechanization of the army for military
competition it was rejected in favor of
an entry
on quote limitations of the tank the
judges were a field marshal and a
general and a colonel
unfortunately liddell hart's entry was
not entirely lost to view why could that
possibly be unfortunate well it's
because along with other products of his
pen it was enthusiastically studied by
hitler's panzer general guardian and
became required reading of the german
general staff
[Applause]
you can't make this up dude
you can't make this up
like those of his fellow protagonists
liddell hart's army career was
prematurely cut short by the military
establishment
the case is germane to the thesis of
this book here is was a man who is
cultured fluent lucid highly intelligent
and that rare combination a soldier who
is also a first class military historian
one whose advice on military matters was
frequently sought by such civilian
leaders as horrible and winston
churchill who in due course became the
military correspondent of the daily
telegraph and subsequently the times
chosen by these papers in preference to
a number of retired generals who applied
for the same job
and hor balisha by the way was the
secretary of war prominent figure
here's a man whose views and writings
were eagerly studied and acted upon by
many foreign powers including germany
russia france and israel whose
prophecies in the military sphere were
borne out time and time again and who
lived to see his ideas on mechanization
and tanks tactics used against us by
germany in 1940
but here was a man so deplored by the
british establishment
by the british military establishment
that lord gort chief of the imperial
general staff at the outbreak of the war
felt moved to say during a lecture to
400 officers of the territorial army
quote kindly remember that liddell hart
does not occupy a room at the war office
so not only do these people that can
kind of play the game
get advanced people that have trouble
playing the game
like liddell hart
get get pushed out
do i wish he could have played the game
a little bit better absolutely do i wish
he would have been a little bit more
indirect you know in in his book when he
talks about if you become a prophet you
get crucified he became a prophet
prophet and he got crucified
it was this same lord gort
the army's top man at the outbreak of
the war whom horbelicia described as a
quote utterly brainless and unable to
grasp the simplest problem these are the
people that are trying to get rid of
liddell hart
liddell hart remarked if a soldier
advocates here's here's exactly what
happens if a soldier advocates any new
idea of real importance he builds up
such a wall of obstruction obstruction
compounded
of resentment suspicion and inertia that
the idea only succeeds at the sacrifice
of himself as the wall finally yields to
the pressure of the new idea it falls
and crushes him and that's what happened
to him
some military leaders even in
democracies have become adept at
manipulating their civilian bosses such
was the case over the issue of war
minister jor
belisha it seems he was not appreciated
by military establishment five reasons
relevant to our general theory of
military incompetence may be advanced
for this for this antipathy
firstly
he was probably brighter than some of
the senior officers with whom he had to
deal secondly his ideas for the army
were progressive thirdly he made no
bones about using liddell heart as his
as his military advisor fourthly he was
with every justification critical of
generals whose job it was to prepare the
british army in france against the
german assault on the west in 1940
fifthly he was a jew
it was a for a mixture of these reasons
that the general staff persuaded
chamberlain to sack the man who had
probably done more for the army and
defense than any other single person
during hitler's rise to power
it's weird how
generals i mean it's not weird it's so
prevalent how generals become
untouchables right
how could you dare say anything about
this general he served his and that's
what's happening here
and and look just because someone served
their country just because someone
served their country
and did a good job as a platoon
commander as a company commander as a
battalion commander it doesn't mean
they're going to be awesome as a general
in fact there's some
some things might indicate that those
aren't very different jobs
especially when they did good as a
company commander or a platoon commander
during world war one when
doing a good job was not disobeying
orders and doing what you were told to
do
and freaking scurrying to a position
where you don't get killed
right because what happened to the brave
soldiers
most of them got freaking killed
we've talked about this thinking
tactically and thinking strategically
are really really different and it's
actually really hard to evolve from a
tactician to a strategist that's not
and in the military there's kind of a
very clear delineation like you're sort
of a tactician as a junior officer and
the middle officers you're sort of like
an operational guy which sits between
them and then the generals are the
strategic thinkers
but that evolution is really hard it's
really hard you talked about peter's
principle i think on the last podcast
yeah where you get promoted to your
level of incompetence that barrier
between tactical thinking and strategic
thinking is hard to overcome yeah well
you run into it with companies as well
where you get some dynamic person and a
startup and they're the ceo of the
company but there's only 48 employees
and they can make things happen and they
kind of impose their will and they can
for they can kind of win the market and
talk to people in a good salesman and it
works out awesome
and then all of a sudden they got
you know 500 employees and they've got a
board and they've got
regulatory environment that they don't
know how to handle and they turn into a
disaster it doesn't always happen but
what we fail to do is we don't really do
a good job of training people and at
least making them aware of the situation
that they're facing
yeah and the other thing i wrote down
was you're talking about this is and i
saw this as i got a little more senior
in the officer ranks and kind of get a
little more observation of that that
general officer tear or that flag
officer tear for the navy is
what gets them there is a bunch of
success
a bunch of success
and
with that set success if you're not
careful what that success can do and
it's not just true in the military it's
true everywhere is that success is this
it equals validation
and if you got to start to get to this
validation like hey
what i'm doing is working you know what
i should do
i should keep doing the same thing and
that flies against what you just talked
about which is the training and the
evolution to think differently
from what you did and one of the
simplest things we see this is hey if i
if i'm a really good at a frontline task
go to that particular task
i'm going to get promoted i'll be the
foreman of this other team and why i'm
the foreman is because i'm really good
at the task but my job isn't to do that
task anymore my job is to think
strategically and lead this team and i
have no skills and no training to do
that because the criteria for getting
promoted
is being good at the task and that
success and that validation sometimes
not always sometimes leads them to a
level
that they're not capable of doing but
the system doesn't allow you to give
them
any feedback because when you're a
general officer guess what
i'm a general officer
there's there's something that you said
that requires a little bit more
exploring
and that is you said that when someone
gets advanced to you know a general
officer or a ceo um
in many cases
it's based on their successes there's
something else it's based on
their lack of failures so
who you know dave and i go on deployment
dave does four operations
they all go okay he gets the job done
jocko goes they we're on the same
deployment you're a task your commander
i'm a task commander my task unit does
170 operations
160 of them go really well and have a
huge impact two of them are jacked up
who gets promoted
who gets promoted this is not like a
theoretical question who gets promoted
yeah i'm getting promoted dave's getting
promoted because i didn't make any
headlines for this screw up i didn't
cause all this equipment and god forbid
somebody got hurt or killed we're not
we're not having a conversation with
dave yeah dave
no friction no resistance no problem for
me no additional paperwork i don't have
to
send an investigation out for what
happened
so yeah and it's not even that extreme
it's really not even that extreme like
you're you're you're making it really
obvious
but it's like hey
you know
dave did four operations they went well
good job jocko did a hundred operations
they had a vehicle rollover
right
um they lost a radio
and
they had a guy get wounded the guy get
wounded
it's like people understand that but oh
you know the vehicle rollover what kind
of
wasn't this is was this really necessary
and all of a sudden it's like well you
know dave kind of keeps his nose clean
he did a good job
who's getting promoted davis
so that's disturbing the other thing is
you look at these these generals
who made it who's getting promoted the
ones that freaking lived how did they
live
they said oh you know sir maybe i could
go back to the rear and and help you
with your strategic planning
you know here's another cup of tea i
really like dave you know he's i want to
bring him back with me makes my ego feel
good
so you're a little brown noser
and then you end up getting living
through world war one and now i put you
under my wing and along you go yeah and
i'm i'm sticking around the army too
after world war ii i can stomach that
whole thing as opposed to all the guys
that came back i'm like
don't ever call me again yeah i'm not
don't don't ever call me again yeah and
not to mention i come back and i'm like
hey look i did my time cool i'm gonna go
out and be an entrepreneur and make
money and build a business you're like
hey i'm kind of scared to get out
i think i'll just stay in here i'll be
getting a paycheck
three hots and a cot
you know i get the uniform
people treat me with respect i'm good
[Music]
back to the book to understand the
psychology of these reactionary elements
in the military establishment of men who
choose to make the army cr their career
painstakingly work their way up the
hierarchy to the highest positions but
then behave in such a manner to ensure
that if they are remembered at all it
will be only for their conservatism we
needs must have recourse
to ego psychology thus it seems
in that in the present instance military
leaders like devarel
montgomery
milne ironside and gort displayed
behavior symptomatic of extremely weak
egos in this light their behavior
typifies the neurotic paradox in which
the individual's need to be loved
breeds
on the one hand an insatiable desire for
admiration with avoidance of criticism
and on the other hand an equally
devouring urge for power and positions
of dominance
that's
weird the paradox is that these needs
inevitably result in behavior so
unrealistic as to earn for the victim
the very criticism which he has been
striving so hard to avoid
consider a few concrete examples of this
syndrome for those who had despaired of
anyone ever learning anything from the
events of the first world war 1933
bought brought a belated gleam of hope
with the publication of the kirk
committee report which was not
uncritical of the high command it could
hardly have been otherwise
but there were those for whom
preservation of personal reputations
counted for more than the need to avoid
the repetition of senseless slaughter to
which their direction had given rise
this is
this is evil i'm going to say that word
this is evil
we have a report that comes out that
explains what we did wrong
and some people they wanted to preserve
their own reputation instead of trying
to save future lives from lessons
learned one such was field marshall
montgomery whose immediate response to
the report was to block its
dissemination throughout the army
while one can wonder at a system which
would make it possible for one man to
operate such censorship the precise
reason for his behavior is by no means
obscure montgomery as he then was
happened to be the chief of staff in the
fourth division
during the battle of the psalm
so he's getting ratted out in this
report
and he's like
puts besides the report
that'd be like if i we had the blue on
blue and ramadi and i was like
hide that stifle it
our second example is rather more
complex concerning
as it does that major obstacle to
military development the horse as
a noble if uncomprehending factor in
military incompetence this animal was
much in evidence between the wars this
is very interesting if you uh know
anything about horses upon reflection is
hardly surprising that the horse became
the
of military life for a thousand years
met had found it in it enormous
advantages there was nothing better for
transportation and load hauling horses
raised morale and enhanced egos horses
took the weight off the feet and enabled
people to go to war sitting down when
they lay down you could hide behind them
when it was cold you could borrow their
warmth and when they died you could eat
them
because of the traditionally rural
origins of so many army officers and
military families horsemanship in the
context of sports like hunting
became one of the prefer preferred
leisure activities in such sports as
polo pig sticking and an earlier age
jousting not only act out symbolic
aspects of real warfare but are also
associated with a higher social class
is little wonder that they should find
so much favor with those who choose the
army as a career all in all it's not
surprising that the cavalry became the
branch of the army with the highest
status nor is it surprising that they
should have become the most vehement in
the denunciation of the tank which was
seen as an intrusive junior rather than
the air inhere apparent so they had this
long fascination with the horse
they loved the horse the people that
rode horses in the cavalry ended up with
a bunch of you know prestigious
positions and high ranking positions and
they saw the tank not as like hey this
is what's going to take over the horse
it's trying to
to to to it's juniors of the horse it's
not as good as the horse
nor is it surprising that the desire of
the war office to placate the cavalry
was stronger lot than logic
not only did they veto
any expansion of the tank corps but
under the direction of montgomery ruled
that the new tank brigade should never
be reassembled and this in the
mid-1930s with hitler arming to the
teeth
that's you can't you you just you have
to have you have to be a kind of like a
psychopath today
there's a level of insanity in there
it's like how how do you look at a horse
in a tank
and look at him go well yeah and you
know i was thinking like
the bolt action rifle or the automatic
machine gun hey fire that one i think
we're actually talking uh sword versus
automatic machine gun i'm just trying to
converse
yeah you gotta go first you gotta go
harder bro yeah that's a fair point it's
just the depths of craziness and look at
that and and kerry was talking about
this after the last podcast
k-dog was talking about this was the
culture of the
of the um
the cavalry and you just said in there
what was it a thousand years
yeah people were using horses in combat
like there's a culture inside there
that's going to be kind of hard to break
into
the tank
come on man
and and it invokes kind of the same
frustration that i articulate in the
very first podcast about the machine gun
no it was before then and when i talked
about the machine gun how long does it
take for me to watch a machine gun mow
down some of my guys where i go time out
stop
stop i got this one wrong we need to
come up with another plan as opposed to
like no
just keep sending them in and do that
for four years for four years at the
risk of
literally i mean millions of people but
but the horse and the tank and even like
old pictures of the world the the crazy
thing about world war one tanks so like
the previous era of tanks that they'd be
leveraging from they're these giant
massive things they're like almost like
comedically too big yeah
but
you if you were to just put those two
side by side
like you said there's a level of
psychopathy level of of of of crazy you
gotta go no the horse yeah
give me the horse give me the sword
dude
there was a little bit of
maybe even a little bit more than a
little um when when we started using
night vision
night vision goggles yeah we talked
about that man we had guys that were
like
we we'd be wearing night vision on
patrol guys but we shouldn't wear night
vision like what are you insane it lets
you see in the dark yeah you get to
fight an enemy that's blind to you yeah
well i've said this and i've i mean in
in in aviation i got to fly stealth
airplanes like very modern cell
airplanes and to this day despite the
insane advantage the insane advantage
there is still an ongoing debate over as
to whether or not
we should have
non-stealth this is not this is a like
in fighters there's reasons to have
nonsense cargo planes and attack planes
like but in this world of like airplane
fighting against another airplane or
using airplanes to get into a contested
space there's still an ongoing debate of
hey we should just retrofit like really
nice legacy airplanes with cool cool
missiles and cool engines and stuff like
that
i
my airplane is invisible
my airplane is invisible you will not
see it
it doesn't matter how fast you can go or
how much gas you can carry or how cool
your weapon is you're going to lose how
much longer till pilots are not doing
this job fighter pilots i think we are
one generation away my opinion is that
the next generation which what's scary
is like it's much sooner it's not like
40 years from now the next generation of
airplanes gonna come out in the next
15-20 years and they're gonna be no
pilots no no i i think this gen like
they're building this now they're
designing and building it now right so
yeah and so technology one of the
drawbacks of airplanes like from
conception to development and building
it takes a long time so this plane has
been on the drawing board for 10 years
and this is what happens when you got
the military industrial complex because
we gave this to elon musk
it's electric and and to his dismay he
probably wants and thinks and
understands that we should be a
generation ahead but be that as it may
even with that i think we've got one
more airplane in us
with a person inside that's my opinion
and
you know even with that it is met with
so much resistance
so much institutional resistance yeah
that's which is crazy right because you
take the pilot out of the plane and and
the other thing is you can you don't
have to fight a plane with a plane you
can fight a plane with 19
unmanned drones that have
that cost a
fraction of the price and can maneuver
and don't have to worry about the stupid
human in there screwing things up and
that's why that story of the naval
officer going you should buy all these
tanks
because he's got no he has no personal
vested interest in the tank he's not
inside that whole thing he's not a
cavalry guy riding horses he's like i'm
over here in a boat i'm just telling you
from my vantage point it's not even
close buy this thing buy them all right
now because he's
he's detached he's just like oh no i'm
not this is not for my personal game i'm
not going to be in that tank or on that
horse i'm just telling you from from
over here it's not it's not even close
just do this
because he sees it from a perspective
and
that's what i think that's where the
that is the level of frustration of
hearing this is really hard because hey
you're
there i said bolt acting rifle and
machine gun like go harder dude go
harder so you know which is like a
slingshot and a heavy machine get an
automatic heavy machine gun that's how
big the gap is and the only way to not
see the machine gun is to be so
invested and so committed to your point
of view that just like we said last time
you will dismiss the truth because it
doesn't align with your preconceived
outcome that you you've created in your
head which is probably to some degree
the definition of being a psychotic
a psychopath
uh by the way they weren't just
anti-tank
uh and this gets into dave burke
territory they were anti-aircraft too
uh here we go for once the for once the
usual rivalry between the two older arms
sank beneath their mutual dislike of the
new upstart if anything the admirals
waxed more
rather more negative about aeroplanes
than they did than did the generals
whose minds as we have seen were already
discomforted by the issue of tanks as
mechanization threatened horses so
aircraft threatened battleships but
unlike horses and military mines
battleships were only the last
succession of obstacles to progressive
naval thinking before battleships it had
been wood and before that sale each
relinquishing each relinquishment and
transition had been bitterly resented
heavily opposed and productive of such
irrational thinking as tends to occur
when dearly loved objects have been
renounced
when this is i've been i've been
referencing this a lot when i talk to
people
when there was talk of iron replacing
wood in the construction of ship one
admiral was heard to remark that the
idea was preposterous since iron was
heavier than water the ships would be
bound to sink
on this issue has been calculated that
and this is fascinating
of the 20 major technological
developments which lie between the first
marine engine and the polaris submarine
the admiral admiralty machine has
discouraged delayed obstruction
obstructed or positively rejected 17.
17 out of 20. the essential and
necessary incorporation of these
developments in the structure of
modernization has been achieved by
individual and sometimes undisciplined
officers by political industrial and
industrial pressures or and most
frequently frequently by their
successful adoption in rival navies
so if you think i i'm going to figure
out some kind of i'm going to figure out
what that list is it's like iron to well
iron to wood and then getting rid of
sales for steam and then from steam to
what you know diesel and then from and
there was people resisted every single
17 out of 20 of those advancements yeah
there was resistance to put a nuclear
reactor on a boat
you imagine the resistance is the best
thing you've ever heard right when
you're doing a submarine are you insane
can't be done can't be done
as for battleships whose future
usefulness and indeed very existence was
threatened by the advent of aircraft
quote to most admirals the respective
value of battleships and aircraft was
not basically a technological issue but
more in the nature of a spiritual issue
totally they cherished the battle fleet
with a religious fervor
as an article of belief defying all
scientific examination the blindness of
hard-headed sailors to realities that
were obvious to a dispassionate observer
is the only explicable through is only
expectable through the through
understanding the place that quote ships
of the line filled their
hearts a battleship had long been to an
admiral what a cathedral is to a bishop
and you can't walk away from that
i don't know
if there is an equivalent in the teams
if there is let me know but
that description is is is beautiful
because in aviation
you literally fall in love with your
airplane like it's a person like it's a
human being and
and the degree to which you cannot see
the truth
is i would say on par to the degree that
you can't see the flaws in your own
children
hey hey jocko you got an ugly baby no i
don't that baby is perfect from head to
toe everything about this thing's unique
and perfect and special and i can't go
and go hey man your kid's got some flaws
here because that is you and the degree
to which pilots
fall in love with the equipment
matches what he described
or like the cathedral that's not an
exaggeration and you will see people
make
these
decisions based on an irrational
physical attachment to a piece of
equipment thank god i flew a bunch of
different airplanes so i kind of like
sort of fell out of love with my first
girlfriend that first airplane but i
still kind of looked
looked back finally go man i really love
that airplane
and to be told hey this thing that you
have is flawed like deeply deeply flawed
and generationally behind where it's
supposed to be and the end rather than
sort of an object you go yeah you're
right there's some things about this
that aren't very good
oftentimes you get just this hyper
irrational emotional response like
you're talking about like i'm not trying
to be critical of your there's a machine
right we're not we're not in love with
the machine aren't we well it's pretty
spot-on yeah that's like when you come
up with a plan and you fall in love with
your own plan and i'm like hey dave not
quite sure about your plan and this
thing what are you talking about talking
about
speaking of emotional detached
it was such strong emotional attachment
that led admirals to deceive their
political masters you can't it doesn't
get any more horrible than this i guess
it does but
the practical issue was whether or not
battleships could defend themselves
against aircraft
having formed the opinion that they
could the admiral the admiralty decided
to prove its point in 1936
while aircraft production by the axis
powers was getting into top gear the
king was invited to a demonstration in
which naval ships would attempt to shoot
down a radio-controlled queen bee target
aircraft
unfortunately the demonstration did not
go well despite the fact that the plane
was limited to flying 80 miles an hour
and flew up and down without jinking
while the ships were given a running
start on a parallel course thereby
reducing the speed differential to
something approaching 50 miles an hour
not a hit was scored
dismayed but resourceful the admirals
played their last card deliberately
crashing the radio-controlled plane into
the sea thereby proving at considerable
cost to the british taxpayer that planes
are no match for the battleship when
these are in the right hands
that's like an act of treason
that's an act of treason
i hate imagining the
actual scene where you're like the
remote control guy and i'm over your
shoulder i'm like do we hit it yet no
hey put that thing in the water and the
guy's like uh seriously put it in the
water now you know like that event had
to occur like in real time or there's
something like hey this isn't going the
way we planned let's sabotage our own
experiment to prove our point that we've
already predetermined which is
planes aren't as good as ships
crash that crash that drone
okay like roger that's her and you like
whatever you do you put that thing in
the water go see look what happened yeah
so that's just like essentially on a big
scale like what you always say
you risk
like some people will
sabotage your plan because they want
their plan to be they want to prove you
know the buck or you know you guys role
play or whatever yeah or if you approach
the guy in the wrong way
he'll be like yeah i'll do your play if
you shove the plan down the guy's throat
right and then they're like okay i'll
carry out your plan and then they might
intentionally sabotage it to prove to
you that hey your plan sucks therefore
we should have went with my plan yeah
yeah
parallel sort of but um
this is actually just
like like treasonous right to just
straight up
why
because you want to protect your little
fifedom
and you are putting the security of your
nation in complete jeopardy
because you're so arrogant and stuck in
your old ways and in love with your
piece of equipment
that's like
that's treason
yeah it's and it's it's also going to
result
in your p your people dying
because the test is actually designed to
go hey
let's see if we can learn some stuff
here hey it turns out this airplane
thing is a good thing we should and
rather than get to the outcome you you
will sabotage the outcome to get
what you want which is i want to show
you my my battleship is still supreme
and the result is you're killing your
own people it's not going to happen for
five years so whatever the timing of
that was but it's going to happen and
we're going to kill hundreds of
thousands of people as a result of that
that's true
i'm trying to remember i had something
happen one time where i was testing some
gps
for and and it was supposed to be
waterproof they're like hey this this
gps is waterproof you don't need to
waterproof it and i was like trust me
how's it
like an e4 e5 and the seal teams going
over the beach all the time i was a
freaking expert
on what was waterproof and what wasn't
and i looked at this thing and i was
like you're saying this thing is
waterproof like that's what you're
saying and they're like yup
and i said no but how do you how should
i prepare it they're like you don't need
to
and i was like
you want me to test this thing and
they're like yeah it's waterproof and i
said okay cool
was not waterproof you know like
not even close and abroad gave them back
their flooded out crappy gps but there
was
there was sort of like indications of
like you know
what did you do you know did you open it
and i was like no i didn't open any of
these things it's not waterproof
but you can see that's the kind of test
where someone goes hey put in a plastic
bag and then say it's waterproof you
know you got some contractor that's
going to sell all these gps's to to
naval special warfare not on my freaking
watch you're not this is a joke
well to quell any potential concern just
that scenario of like that that
pre-world war ii you know
battleship airplane british thing we're
just like hey we're just gonna sabotage
and just falsify the results i never saw
anything to that degree i saw some
resistance for sure but i never saw
anybody or ever heard anybody
hey
falsify the report sabotage the plan so
just so people realize like i in my
experience and i had some interesting
things happen in my career i never saw
that
i'm trying i don't think i have either
um
yeah i'll have to i'll have to think on
that one but i probably would have stood
out so much yeah i mean somebody over my
shoulder saying hey
put that thing in a waterproof bag and
call it good like what do you thought i
would have never done that in a thousand
years yeah
i love the image willing to put that
drone in the water sir what do you mean
crash it immediately until everybody got
shot down what's funny is we crashed
some drones as a matter of fact we were
in uh we're going through
through
urban combat training and tasking the
bruiser and we're supposed to be using
these drones and
everything freaking
aoic
it was one of the latest aoycs was like
a drone pilot
and
whatever he was doing like he's like all
right i'm going you know we're flying
gonna go look at the target and he he
bring tries to bring it back and this
thing came in at like well i don't know
how fast those things go what would be a
realistic speed for a drone 50 knots
this thing comes in at 50 knots it just
way lays into a tree
and of course they're like hey you know
how's that drone working out i'd be like
that drone sucks and the advancement on
drones between that time frame 2005 and
now is like night and day but if i would
have been setting up the reporter
whoever would have been something yeah
these things are great no we'd be like
this thing sucks this thing sucks make
it better and that's what they did so
thankfully
we also didn't like uh
falsify stuff all right
those that's that that's now we're
moving into the second world war the pre
the pre the the in between war period is
over nothing learned nothing figured out
no no one taking blame responsibility
for anything second world war
there's a quote in here from liddell
hart
the german success in may 1940 could
easily have been prevented but for the
opportunities presented to them by the
allied blunders blunders that were
largely due to the prevalence of
out-of-date ideas
after an appalling start in which the
allies were out fought out maneuvered
and outstripped in the quality of their
military thinking and equipment the
second world war produced the biggest
transition in military confidence since
the days of wellington it was born of
necessity and may be said to have dated
from dunkirk this jolt to 100 years of
military monitoring and 20 years of
blind complacency achieved three ends
within a space of days it shattered many
long held
dearly loved illusions about the nature
of modern war it hastened the eclipse of
the old the reactionary and the
untalented finally by rendering the
armory temporary impotent dunkirk put
the most junior service in the center of
the stage dave burke is excited now the
first time
the continued existence of the army and
navy became totally dependent
upon their protection by the raf
look at this smile on this guy over here
as for the bad start
this was a legacy of factors that
touched on the previous chapters
rigidity of thinking
overconfidence resulting from a pathetic
belief in antiquated methods of warfare
and refusal to accept that enemy
intentions may confound the armchair
prophets
the following examples from labelle
hearts history of the second war
illustrate these shortcomings on january
10 1940 a german aircraft carrying the
liaison officer of the second air fleet
lost its way and crash landed in belgium
by an extraordinary chance the officer
was in possession of the complete
operational plan for germany's attack on
the west
did you hear what i just said
by extraordinary chance the officer was
in possession of the complete
operational plan for germany's attack on
the west he tried to burn the plan but
failed to complete this task before he
was captured in this way its contents
became known to the allies hitler's
response was to devise a new plan which
involved attacking france through the
ardennes rather than through belgium as
originally intended
this episode was damaging to the allies
for two reasons first
firstly in the belief that the captured
plan was a deliberate deception they
failed to modify their own plans
secondly contrary to advice received
years earlier they clung to the belief
that the wooded area of the ardennes was
impassable to tanks
as a result the strongest allied force
remained poised for attack through
belgium while the germans suffered
little resistance to their outflanking
drive through the ardennes
here's another one the french though
possessing many tanks which were as good
as if not better than those of the
germans were steadfast in their belief
that horsed cavalry could destroy german
armor in the ardennes
for this reason they refused to accept
the suggestion that felled trees might
be used to delay the german advance like
the poles they were sadly disillusioned
about the outcome of a conflict between
horse and tanks
that's the poles and the french
both making the assessment that hey you
got tanks but we got horses
the british retreat from the ghazala
line in 1942 which resulted in the loss
of tobruk
followed by a headlong flight back into
egypt
was the second worst disaster of the war
after dunkirk towbrook cost britain 35
000 casualties and an enormous loss in
ground and materiel why did it happen
inadequate generalship the army
commander major general neil richie a
fine looking man has been described by
his contemporaries in ways strikingly
resembling of elphinstone raglan and
buller
here's here's here's what his
contemporaries had to say about him
richie was all haywire by then all for
counter-attacking in this direction one
day and another the next optimistic and
not and trying not to believe we had
taken a knock when i reported the state
of the first armored division to him at
a time when i was planning to use it for
a counter-attack he flew to see me and
almost took the view that i was being
subversive
another one general richie had a great
air of decisiveness
it was really rather indecisive
according to the same core commander he
quote had a tendency to ask your advice
and having received it acted the
opposite way here's another one richie
is not sufficiently quick-witted or
imaginative imaginative
another one a fine robust looking man
with charm and manner but no aura
and finally confident and decisive in
his speech
but one did not always feel he was quite
so confident and decisive in his mind
that's another thing i talked about that
i think on the first one this act that
you learn yeah you learn to kind of
raise your voice a little bit you learn
to project you learn to furrow your
eyebrows a little bit and you say hey
listen burke i love doing that right
because it's something that we
experience so much in the military
listen up burke hey i don't need your
input right now hey look we need to make
a move burke you know like that thing
people learn that in the military you
learn how to act like that
and eventually you can learn how to hide
behind that
you see that all the time so and people
get fooled by civilians get fooled like
by that but like it's going out of style
i mean that's what they're looking for
they're looking for the type cast
colonel the type cast general that furs
brow sits up straight with a good
posture
and then speaks in a clear effective
manner that people are going to listen
to
and the politicians love to take that
guy and put them out there to put out
the word
you know
well you know what i'm saying they do
they take that guy they put him out
there
hey you know what we got willing
we only can put on an act no one's going
to mess with willing but willing on the
stand
paul willink on the stand
willing gets and he puts his uniform on
freaking puts his shoulders back chest
out and then says i'm going to tell you
this one time here's how it is going to
happen boom people aren't questioning
that
fast forward a little bit under the
ineffectual leadership of this big
kindly courteous unimaginative
apparently complacent yet occasionally
touchy general the army suffered a
decline in organization discipline and
drive it became flabby instead of taught
sluggish instead of agile once again
that faded fatal amalgam of
overconfidence and underestimation of
the enemy produced a dulling of military
endeavor rommel himself in his diary
ascribed his success to the british
predilection for
frontal assaults
brave but costly charges by small groups
in which the attackers banged their
heads time and time again against the
hull down german panzers
hold down yeah let's do a frontal
assault against a tank yep and hold
that's yeah that's whole down meaning
meaning they've positioned themselves
where the hole is you can't see the tank
you can only see the turret that's
hauled down echo charles yes sir hold
down defilet you parked that thing
in a little berm in a little ravine and
you can't see it the only thing you see
is this like the gun yeah and guess when
you see the turret yeah
five seconds before it lights you up and
you're just walking right up on that
thing
dude
it's hard to picture that because you
know
you know the story of
the hey the french are going to dig this
hey you know what we should do a deeper
longer wider trench
and a forest that's impassable by armor
like that's their plan yeah hey what did
we learn hey i got an idea hey remember
the trench we didn't order one not good
enough let's dig a deeper trench and
they're 100 sure that the armor can't go
through this forest so
we're good and we all know that story so
you're just waiting to hear this this be
revealed
which is the idea of
hey the horses you know this this this
forest is impassable by equipment so you
know you're going to need some horses
yeah you know what i'm going to had when
i found some trees when i had ben
milligan on
fr from his book um
by water beneath the walls one of the
interesting things the
like the marines had issues at tarawa
and their solution
like hey we our tracks didn't make it
through and some of our marines didn't
make to the beach because they hit um
you know hit the the reef 800 meters out
marine's solution was okay
guess what real simple we need more more
marines and more tracks
we need we need you know 80 tracks to
make it through and half them don't make
it cool 160 is the number yeah
and
the the the navy was like how about we
go and
you know try and figure out where those
reefs are
hence udts
if you didn't listen to that podcast i
think it's 298 with ben milligan and get
that book
get that book that freaking book is
outstanding by water beneath the waves
talk about uh
going into depth and figuring out and
understanding why things are the way
they are it's an outstanding book
from the standpoint of human behavior
human feelings leadership and decision
making the events of 1942 in north
africa
exemplify in microcosm the major causes
of military incompetence underneath his
robust exterior richie like buller
before him an elf and stone before him
lacked self-confidence and seemed more
concerned with proving himself to
himself than with prosecuting the war
the presiding over interminable
committee meetings
through which the army was run the
seeking of advice and then not taking it
and the disingenuous way in which he
managed to convince the
commander-in-chief that he was
protecting tobruk while in reality
leaving it to the mercy of the germans
are the actions of a man beset by inner
doubts
these doubts were skillfully but not
perfectly concealed by his often
inappropriate facade of monumental
complacency
now we go to singapore chapter 11.
one can sum up
by saying that those responsible for the
conduct of the land campaign in malaya
committed every conceivable blunder
major general woodburn kirby singapore
the chain of disaster
in the nine weeks
between early december 1941 and mid
february 1942 the impregnable force
fortress of singapore europe's gateway
to the east
with its thriving city huge naval
dockyard and strategic vital airfields
fell lock stock and barrel into the
hands of the japanese the invasion of
this island stronghold the complete
defeat of the
combined british and australian garrison
with its army navy and air force units
was the ultimate unconditional surrender
of the whole area was so rapid that even
the japanese were staggered indeed one
almost
might say non-plussed by the ease speed
and enormity of their success
in the long run the results of this
disaster may be deemed incalculable
the myth of european supremacy over
asiatic peoples was exploded forever and
the prestige of competence of the
british military endeavor in the eyes
the world in general and america in
particular were damaged beyond repair in
the short run britain lost her last and
strongest foothold in the far east an
appalling setback for the global war
effort effort we lost thousands of lives
both military and civilian but worse
perhaps than the loss of life the
military debacle condemned thousands
more to three and a half years japan
misery in japanese internment camps
finally the economic loss ran into
hundreds of millions of pounds
we forfeited elaborate and expensive
dock installations naval and other
engineering facilities military stores
fuel the major port for exporting
urgently needed rubber and two new first
class battleships
most of these material assets fell
virtually intact into the hands of the
enemy thus in effect doubling their
value
the value of their loss to the allies
like other cases we have discussed that
of singapore is essentially a human
problem a product of human behavior
human intellect intellect human
character and human error no explanation
in terms of geography climate broad
political or military considerations can
possibly do justice to the facts
at bottom and at the top we are
confronted with issues that are
primarily psychological and which only a
reduction to psychological principles
can possibly explain so this freaking
disaster unfolds in
singapore a disaster
and as you're gonna see it's not about
who is smart and it's not about like the
military situation it's the freaking
psychopathology of the the leaders
let us state the problem in terms of a
number of questions why was the
impregnable fortress planned and
serviced in such a way that while
presenting apparently formidable
defenses on its southern side its back
and northern shure was no more of a
resistance than would-be invader than
the back of bournemouth
why was there an almost total lack of
coordination and cooperation between
those who had been entrusted with the
job of defending the island why was it
clear that the japanese could and would
assault the island from its northern
northern side was nothing done to erect
defenses in their path why did the
the general officer commanding singapore
lieutenant general percival ignored the
urgent advice of his subordinate
brigadier simpson and of his superior
general wavel
to implement these defenses why on the
one hand was so little done to protect
the civilian population against air
raids and on the other
so much done to prevent their knowing
the true facts of the situation as these
unfolded why did general percival
persist in believing the japanese would
attack from the northeast when
confronted with overwhelming evidence
that their assault would come from the
northwest why did the officer commanding
the australian forces on the island
forbid his troops to escape while
secretly plotting his own getaway from
the island
finally and perhaps greatest of greatest
interest how did the men who could
perpetrate such colossal errors of
judgment ever reach a position where
this was possible
it's quite the setup
in 1925 there was a protracted and
acrimonious argument between the army
navy and air force chiefs as to how
singapore should be defended
while the older services pressed for
fortifications and heavy-fixed guns to
repel an attack from seaward trencher
for the raf advocated for a large force
of aircraft to repel any attack before
could become come within range of the
island needless to say the army in the
navy won their case at the expense of
more junior service heavy fixed army
armaments became the order of the day
this debate in which the raf had to
concede defeat had three unfortunate
consequences firstly the island was left
exposed and undefended on its northern
side secondly senior army commanders
from that time on stubbornly clung to
the dogma that no japanese would ever
advance on singapore down the malay
peninsula finally the bitter inner
service quarrel which ensued resulted in
an almost total lack of coordination
between the three services
for future
reference let me say this
dave you have a platoon
in your platoon there's a two different
let's call them clicks
and they have two different ideas of
what you should be focused on and how
you should operate
and what you do is you sort of negotiate
a piece between these two clicks and you
sort of compromise and you figure out
hey like we'll do a little bit of this
click a little bit of that click and you
kind of you kind of bring these forces
to a
compromise
you get them working together you get
them to like take these things that they
could be arguing about you you give one
here and give the other side one here
and so you you end up with a team that
although they're not perfectly in sync
they're at least sort of
working together
my platoon i have two clicks
and what i do is i get mad at them
because they don't get along
and then i agree with one of the clicks
actually a little bit more and so i give
them favoritism and now we end up with
this you know head butting
who's got a better platoon
right so
if you think about this in a large
strategic view
and you look at a place called the
united states of america right now
and you look at how miraculously or
strangely
we've become super divisive about all
kinds of things to the point where we
are banging against each other's heads
and we don't get along
and we've got people that sit so far
apart in their beliefs not only do they
sit so far apart in their beliefs they
can't find common ground on anything
on anything
and we've got
known
known actors in the world
[Music]
that make moves
to increase the division between the
sides of people that we have in america
and the people in america don't even
recognize that all of this fighting
is making our platoon weak
it's very interesting isn't it
it's very interesting that we know
that there are actors that are cr there
are state actors that are creating
divisiveness in our own country and yet
instead of saying hey you know what
actually we we shouldn't argue about
that stuff hey you know what dave you
got your opinion on that i got my
opinion but you know what there's a
bunch of stuff we agree on let's focus
on that
okay you know what that makes sense we
can go execute the mission now
instead no you know what dave you don't
agree with me on this well screw you i
don't even want to work with you
now we can't operate we can't get
anything done
so obvious
yeah it's so obvious it's hard to look
at too because not only are you going to
disagree with me you can actively
actively sabotage my efforts 100 and and
the hardest part about that is that the
reality is we are on the same team
those two
those two platoons in your task unit
they're on the same team
they're very disturbing
i've been trying i've got to think a way
to articulate that a little bit more
clearly
and
and present it in a way that people can
see it but it's very difficult because
when you present it if i present it to
the platoon and say hey guys i think it
looks like we're we're actually
looks like
we're actually not uh helping here we're
not moving this thing forward
you know what one side says oh so you're
trying to take their side are you yeah
that's exactly what happens that's and
that's the point i was thinking when you
said that when when you you know you you
you were sort of over like i show a
little bias towards this one team
which is
all the other side needs to go oh i see
what side you're on oh yeah i see what
you're i don't trust you're one of them
yeah i see what you're getting at
so i've got to think of a way to
articulate this properly people because
right now
but we don't understand it as americans
we are in this sort of trap where
there's a total lack of coordination
between the different sides yeah our
government can't even get anything done
they're they're they're they're losers
they're just not not making any progress
and all they're doing is fighting with
each other and not realizing that while
we're fighting each other
number one there's other state actors
that are that are
feeding this fight
and while they're while they're feeding
our fight and we're having these
infights guess what these other state
actors are doing
growing their economy
unifying their people
[Music]
growing their military
strength growing the will of their
people
and we are being divided
i'll think of a way to try and
communicate this so people will
hopefully start to understand it
i haven't done a good job thus far
meanwhile
back on singapore there's a total lack
of coordination between the three
services the reason this is such a
fitting thing is because you're going to
see what happens in singapore when you
don't work together
and when your ego oh yeah by the way
dave i think i know everything and so
therefore how can you possibly be right
on anything at all yeah
you certainly know you're right oh i
definitely know i'm right
the raf began constructing airfields
without consultation with the army who
would have to defend them so there's a
great move
uh japanese military machine was oh yeah
this was the belief was look the
japanese
they're primitive they're not going to
be able to we should we shouldn't even
take them seriously
thus and now fast forward a little bit
thus when the malay tribune published
the news that japanese transports had
been sighted off the southern tip of
indochina the editor was immediately
castigated by the commander-in-chief of
the far east air chief marshal sir
robert brooke ponham popham who said i
consider it most improper to print such
alarmist views at a time like the
present
the position isn't half so serious as
the tribune makes out and this is such a
great little section he says this form
of complaint is not without interest
firstly he did not deny the truth of the
press release he hardly could since it
had originated in a report by reuters
which has been passed by the censor and
which undoubtedly was true
secondly he managed to imply all in one
breath that the situation was both not
serious and yet likely to cause alarm
like why are you causing alarm like this
dave and by the way there's nothing to
be panicked about
uh his words exemplified a tendency seen
all too often to talk down to a civilian
population as a group through some
weakness of intellect or lack of moral
fiber oh sorry who through some weakness
of intellect or lack of moral fiber
could not be trusted with information
held by their elders and betters i mean
the military is like you don't really
know what's going on here
you need to worry about that the
guardians of singapore were prime
exemplars of this motivation after a
long history of wrong thinking they
could not afford to be found mistaken
the more events proved them to be wrong
the stronger their defenses became
against admitting this to be the case
and this is very important as hitler's
administer administration demonstrated
in its starkest form
man this is important
suppression of the truth involves two
procedures
on the one hand censorship and on the
other hand official communiques
the high command in singapore employed
both measures
take the order of the day released to
the melee tribune a bear two months
before singapore capitulated it reads
we are ready
we have
had plenty of warning and our
preparations are made and tested we are
confident our defenses are strong and
our weapons efficient whatever our race
we have one aim and one only it is to
defend these shores to destroy such of
our enemies as may set foot on our soil
what of our enemy we have seen before us
japan drained for years by exhausting
claims of her wanton onslaught of china
let us all remember that we here in the
far east form part of the great campaign
in the world of truth and justice and
freedom
as the editor of the tribune said it was
hard to believe that anybody could
deliberately tell so many lies
on monday the 18th
general headquarters issued its first
war communique it stated that the
japanese had failed in their attempt to
land at kotabaru
this was followed shortly after by a
second communique which stated all
surface craft are retiring at high speed
and the few troops left on the beach are
being heavily machine gunned
in fact the communique was essentially
untrue and deliberately misleading
within a space of a few hours from the
time of the japanese landing kotabaru
was firmly in enemy hands
uh there's a couple battleships as a
desperate medal measure two battleships
the prince of wales and the repulse were
sent to singapore to create an 11th hour
presence they were under the command of
admiral sir tom phillips in the words of
one who met him quote a real old sea dog
bluff and tough unfortunately
he lacks sufficient
vision
despite strong warnings that he could
not expect adequate air cover he was
soon off with his two ships in search of
trouble
at first all went well as the ship
steamed reassuringly up the east coast
when he heard that there was weather so
he thought he'd be okay his ships bled
the weather lifted his ships were
spotted by japanese air force torpedoed
and sunk with a total loss of 840
officers and men by all accounts
phillips was was a brave and
conscientious officer but his braveness
bordered on foolhardiness and his errors
of judgment not only had a devastating
effect on that much cherished commodity
but the morale of the singapore
civilians also sealed the fate of their
city
so much for the navy in their chosen
field the senior
command of the raf acquitted themselves
little better better
it has already been seen how air chief
marshal brook pompum
underestimated japan's air strength in
comparison with his own ill assorted
group of obsolete aircraft the same 63
year old officer whose most notable
characteristic was a tendency to fall
asleep on the slightest pretext showed
such disastrous hesitancy
and indecision in his capacity as
commander-in-chief that as the official
history was moved to state quote it is
possible that he did not fully realize
the importance of speed the need for
quick decision was not apparently
realized at headquarters malaya command
and this is something i talked about
earlier the first night raid
they get it they get a warning 30
minutes early that there's a japanese
inbound
and um they didn't do anything it seems
the japanese had committed the
unforgivable faux pas attacking at night
unforgivable because it conflicted with
the official dogma that the japanese
were unable to fly their planes during
the hours of darkness
this idea cost singapore 61 dead and 133
injured but the recklessness of the
admirals and the dithering of the air
marshals were nothing
as
to the
uncompromising
of the generals it seemed that nothing
could move them not even pleading of
their fellow officers as noah barber
says in his book sinister twilight
quote when big brigadier general simpson
and you remember this is like the good
guy when brigadier general simpson the
chief engineer went to see major general
gordon bennett commanding the 8th
australian division he found it
impossible to make him realize that
there was an urgent need for anti-tank
defenses at first he did not want to
discuss the matter at all simpson noted
after the meeting simpson was horrified
could not the australian general
understand that there was nothing on the
long road to prevent the enemy from
reaching them apparently gordon bennett
could not for in his diary that night he
wrote malay command sent brigadier
simpson to discuss with me the creation
of anti-tank obstacles for use on the
road personally have little time for
these obstacles preferring to stop and
destroy tanks with anti-tank weapons
no wonder that the japanese never slowed
down no wonder that time after time
troops were annihilated by skillful
japanese enveloping tactics on the
british side wrong decisions were made
communications broke down whole pockets
of troops were cut off first japanese
tanks appeared and came
as a great surprise to the british who
had not one single tank in malaya
in a jungle country where the british
had insisted that tanks could never
operate the japanese tanks moved easily
between spacious rows of rubber tree
end quote major general gordon bennett
was not to use the appropriate
vernacular and isolated pocket of
resistance nor did he hold the record of
obstinacy in barber's words attempts by
brigadier simpson to move and add to the
defenses had been balked at at every
turn largely by general general percival
who seemed to have had a fixation
against such measures nothing had been
done nothing was being done despite
previous pleas a hazard of belonging to
any rigidity
any rigidly authoritarian hierarchical
organization is that from time to time
the individual out of dire necessity or
from strong personal conviction feels
compelled to apply pressures to those
above him
it is a hazard because the ethos of the
organization whether it be a victorian
family an english boarding school or the
british army demands that pressure
always moves only in one way downwards
rather than upwards
to buck the system by prodding those
above can have unpleasant consequences
you're gonna totally freaking rigid
situation
and simpson is trying
simpson is trying i'm gonna fast for a
little bit it seems that simpson was
past taking no for an answer for he said
to the general sir i must emphasize the
urgency of doing everything to help our
troops they're often only partially
trained they're tired and dispirited
they've been retreating for hundreds of
miles and please remember sir the
japanese are better trained better
equipped and they are inspired by an
unbroken run of victories and it has to
be done now sir once the area comes
under fire civilian labor will vanish
he's wanting to get these just just get
freaking obstacles set up
the plea was forceful respectful and
logical but amazingly the general
remained unmoved simpson in his rising
anger said look here general i've raised
this question time after time you've
always refused what more you've always
refused to give me any reasons at least
tell me one thing why on earth are you
taking this stand who's like hey why the
hell don't you want me to build
obstacles what's wrong with you why not
at long last the general officer
commanding malaya gave his answer quote
i believe the defenses of the sort you
want to throw up are bad for the morale
of the troops and civilians end quote
simpson was quote frankly horrified and
remembers standing there in the room
suddenly feeling quite cold and
realizing that except for a miracle
singapore was as good as lost
as he put on his sam brown sims could
not for beer to make one last remark
quote sir it is going to be much worse
for morale if the japanese start running
all over the island
you can't make it dude that is so hard
to listen to and for whatever sense of
validation in my head of as soon as he
said it's bad from wrong my first
thought was you know what's worse for
morale
and of course you know i don't know what
he's going to say but i understand that
that's what this guy is seeing or
thinking and you saying that doesn't
make me feel any better because
it's just i mean i'm just getting
repetitive at this point it's just a you
have to be crazy to not accept
to not accept the facts that don't align
with
the worldview you've created in your
head yeah and i i'm only reading chunks
of the book it's even worse than it's
worse than i'm making it sound
and i have the distinct disadvantage of
seeing
how much of this how much you've gone
through and going wow there's chunk i
mean big big chunks which i can only
assume
just has reinforced over and over again
another example another example another
example another example
and this dude is a good writer and he's
a good writer and you and i'm glad that
in the very beginning you set this up
this
this isn't a researcher
this isn't like a a theorist or or a
you know an academic he has all those
pedigrees
this guy fought this guy fought and was
born he was a warrior he understood yes
yes
by his own incompetence
yeah which is awesome so
yeah this is this is rough and i think
what i'm still adding to this is just i
think it's at a point of repetition of
just
it it's really hard to accept that these
are real stories from real people in
real leadership positions leading up to
what was
just
people getting slaughtered
you know like you said he was a soldier
but he's also a psychologist and so he
gives these psychological assessments
too so here's here's one of them in the
case of percival and gordon bennett to
erect defenses would have been to admit
to themselves the danger in which they
stood in other words their professional
anxiety about civilian morale was really
displaced anxiety about their own morale
looking further into the story of
singapore one is struck by the
compulsive element in this refusal of
the military to defend itself
such compulsive behavior is typical of
many who present an authoritarian
personality and are reared in an
organization which traditionally deals
with fear and danger by reach
ritualistic means
i.e chicken
drill and parades etc
or is what i think he referred to
earlier is like the real business of
soldiering we're going to get back to
you know um drilling ceremonies so
there's a there's a admiral that comes
along or yeah uh
who was it
supreme commander of allied forces in
the far east this guy archibald wavel
and he
he shows up and it's kind of like what
the hell's going on bro
uh so then next thing that happens is a
director from churchill giving detailed
instructions on how to defend the north
shore the measures listed were precisely
those which had been advocated by
simpson
but despite these pressures
percival still did nothing when he
eventually issued a plan it was already
too late for the necessary civilian
labor was no longer available just as
simpson has said it was going to be on
the disposition of his forces percival's
thinking seemed no less deranged
rather than hold a force in reserve that
could ru could be rushed quickly to
wherever the japanese eventually chose
to land he decided to spread his troops
thinly over a long front
in other words he decided now
because it would be good for morale just
exactly what he had refused to do early
because it would be bad for morale
in this battle of singapore and they put
that in quotes order of the day first of
all made it made
great play of phrases like the enemy
within our gates loose talk and rumor
mongering all calculated to alarm
civilians
and this from the man who had laid such
stress on the importance of civilian
morale
of this period barbara writes in all the
catalogue of ineffectual leadership
nothing is quite so public puzzling as
the virtual absence of any deterrent
action during the last precious hours of
daylight before the japanese attacked it
is hard to believe that a modern general
could so easily ignore what was
happening around him
that's i've never heard quite as bold of
a statement as in all the catalog of
ineffectual leadership that's a bold one
yeah that's a big catalog
says for the allies
it was a week of chaos and confusion
unrelieved by any vestiges of competent
leadership or generalship
thanks to the absence of defenses
including a failure to use searchlights
which had been assembled to blind and
make targets of the attackers as they
paddled their way across
the johor straits the japanese landed
almost unmolested
despite a devastating barrage from
japanese artillery
british guns instead of pounding the
enemy's point of embarkation
remained mute
awaiting orders that never
came despite weeks of warning allied
ground forces were speedily outflanked
encircled cut off or routed
in the event
708 british indian and australian
soldiers either died or went into
captivity
this is the beginning if you've listened
to podcast number 12 aleister
urquhart the forgotten highlander this
is this is where he starts his
captivity
i think he'd been in the army for like
two or three months at this point 19
years old
138 000 in one event
[Music]
of all the instances of military
incompetence considered in this book is
the fall of singapore which most clearly
gives the lie to the so-called bloody
fool theory of military ineptitude
percival was in fact highly intelligent
and had shown himself in pre previous
years to be a brilliant staff officer
what he shared with other earlier
military incompetents were passivity
the opposite of default aggressive by
the way
and courtesy
rigidity
and obstinacy procrastination
gentleness
and dogmatism
138 thousand
two battleships by the way
insane
the next chapter
is about
rnm
um
this is one we covered we covered so we
covered part of singapore obviously when
we covered alexander ercart
rm we covered podcast 94.
the the book was called men at arnhem
written by jeffrey powell who was there
who fought there
and i think you know when you read
reading this assessment
really puts it really puts that book
into perspective it starts off with this
couple quotes all the accumulated
evidence confirms that like gallipoli
this was a british disaster where naked
courage lacked the bodyguard of
competent planning competent
intelligence competent technology
yet war's object is victory not the
victoria cross
and it was shameful that by autumn of
we could still be so amateur
the object is victory not the victoria
cross we don't that's the equivalent of
the medal of honor in england
here's a private soldier's comments it
began to seem to me that the generals
had got us into something they had no
business doing
if it achieved nothing else operation
market garden montgomery's plan to
capture and hold a bridgehead across the
rhine in northern holland at least
demolishes the myth that military
incompetence stems from stupidity
for sheer initiative quickness of mind
fortitude and selfless heroism the
conduct of those who actually fought the
battle has never been surpassed
by the same token the men who planned
and administered the operation were
probably as intellectually gifted
well-trained professionally competent
dedicated and conscientious as any
military planners have ever been
and yet the unfolding of market garden
revealed all the symptoms of high-level
military incompetence
you that's like incred
how would you feel if someone said you
know what dave you're intellectually
gifted well trained professionally
competent dedicated and conscientious
that's what we're looking for in our
leaders and yet this thing is a disaster
the failure of the operation resulted
from a a linked
together
of the following factors
one as a result of his neglect to open
up the port of antwerp by clearing the
schle the shelled estuary montgomery
allowed the german 15th army to escape
north into holland where it was
available to defend the approaches to
archanam
two
the arrival at arnhem of 30 core
depended upon the advancing across 64
miles of enemy held territory on a one
tank front along elevated unprotected
highways flanked by a soft and tank and
sodden tank proof landscape interspersed
with waterways
any delay a blown bridge an enemy ambush
a blocked road and the entire column
would be stopped any delay and the
germans would have more time to bring up
reinforcements in the event it is hardly
surprising that 30 core never did reach
arnhem
that they could not achieve it even in
nine days what had been scheduled to
take 48 hours now
i'm going to say i know i gave credit to
your 12 year old daughter
and i'm going to say
your 12 year old daughter might not be
able to figure this one out look you're
looking you got to go 60 what is it 60
miles 67 miles 64 miles
but
pretty much
any lance corporal in the marine corps
sees a channelized 64 mile
road
that's completely exposed to the enemy
and doesn't like this plan yeah
if i'm hearing it correctly what you're
describing is a one essentially a one
it's a he called it a single tank a
one-lane highway which on either side is
impassable yeah due to you know canals
and and and the terrain whatever it is
it's impossible you have a one-lane
highway and your entire formation is
going to be a single file yep that's how
this is going to work and he mentions we
might get ambushed right or or we might
get a blown bridge how about this a
broken down tank
how about how about we have a freaking
crash
number three
as might have been expected from what is
known of english autumns the mists if
not the mellow fruitfulness of the of an
english late september delayed the
departure of subsequent gliders and
paratroopers for the reinforcement of
the first armored division
like we didn't think there might be fog
in the morning we're in england england
market garden perhaps more than most
military operations necessitated good
communication between the various units
and commanders of the attacking force
but here technology failed them
though it was now 50 years since marconi
had succeeded in sending messages by
wireless the radio sets carried by the
invasion force proved useless
unless with an earshot of each other no
one knew what anyone else was doing and
look i
you can say technology failed them
if i'm a freaking military planner
and i'm relying on the communications in
that's what's going to make us
successful you're an idiot
we could barely rely on communications
10 years ago we can rely on them a lot
more now
maybe okay not 10 years ago sorry uh 20
years ago 20 years ago
you're barely you're barely like to the
year 2000 you're barely thinking oh yeah
we don't we will get comms
we had backup comms all the time backup
communication plans we had all the time
and you know what we had them in ramadi
as well of course yeah so to think that
your comms is going to be good to go in
that's not technology thing that's a
freaking lack of planning yeah
a single point of failure of prob of
probably the most critical thing you're
able to do
is talk yeah more than employ your
weapons even more than moving your
ability to talk is probably the most
critical thing that you have to
coordinate all these different assets
all these different things going on
i can't secondary i mean we had i
remember when i was in ramadi because as
an anglico marine
coms was my was really the number one
thing it was secondary to the to the
utilization of the aircraft number one
it was comp so we had this incredible
comm suite and every brief was hey let's
hire let's create the prioritization of
how we're going to communicate and it
was based on where we were how far away
we're going to be what assets were
available if i have a humvee
cool i got a vehicle it's powered i got
this high powered antenna i've got these
cool powered radios and if i gotta get
out of that humvee and start walking i
don't have that thing anymore so i could
have a backup plan yeah and every single
mission i went on me and my radio
operator talked about
if this doesn't work what are we gonna
do
and guess what
stuff
the nicest best high ste texas didn't
work routinely yep and by the way what
are you doing then you're getting out
your signal panel
right we're marking our positions with a
big orange panel
number five since the airborne assault
was to take place in daylight
and because it was vital that 30 core
should complete their journey within 48
hours
64 miles and 48 hours on a single track
the whole enterprise depended upon the
absence of strong german forces both in
arnhem
area and on the approach route from the
south hence it came of something as a
jolt
when they received reports from the
dutch underground that two ss panzer
divisions which had mysteriously
disappeared sometime previously had now
reappeared alongside almost alongside
the dropping zone this information
passed on to montgomery received support
from the british aerial photography
of german tanks in the arnhem area
meanwhile forward troops of the british
second army reported a buildup of german
forces along their intended line of
advance
might want to reconsider
this is the moment to reassess the risks
involved but since these ugly facts did
not accord with what they had planned
they fell upon a succession of deaf
air's ears
taking the lead from montgomery
who described the report as ridiculous
british second army headquarters were
quick to discount it also
when one of his intelligence officers
showed him the aerial photographs of
german armor general browning
at first british airborne headquarters
retorted i wouldn't trouble myself about
these if i were you they are probably
not serviceable at any rate
is there any stronger form of just
straight like denial and idiocy than
that right there you get shown the first
you get intel reports and then you get
shown photographs of the armor tanks the
german tanks on the ground and you're
like they're probably not serviceable
you can't make this up
you also know that there's two divisions
there that are gone
it's it's they didn't appear out of
nowhere you know these divisions existed
yeah that's
the intelligence officer was then
visited by the core medical officer who
suggested he should take some leave
because he was so obviously exhausted
and at first allied army headquarters
the chief intelligence officer british
british lieutenant colonel decided there
was no direct evidence that the arnhem
area contained quote much more than the
considerable flack defenses already
known to exist
as ryan puts it quote all down the
allied line of command the evaluation of
intelligence on the panzers in arnhem
area was magnificently bungled
finally just in case there were any
residual doubts the intelligent staff of
the second army came up with the
reassuring opinion that any german
forces in the arnhem area were
quote weak demoralized and likely to
collapse if confronted with a large
airborne attack
that's insane
the freaking nazis
the nazis are trying to defend their
reich
fighting for their lives
they're fighting for their country
they know what happens if they lose
they're some of the finest fighting
forces in the world and yet we're just
going to go ahead and catalog them as
weak demoralized and likely to collapse
and by the way randomly they just if
they're confronted with a large airborne
attack like that's the thing
because hey when you're an airborne
attack because that means you you do you
even have anti-tank weapons barely
you've got no armor this is ridiculous
market garden went ahead
but not so quite as planned
instead of encountering a few old men
who collapsed or ran away first airborne
division fell upon a hornet's nest of
german armor armor
far from being demoralized
the enemy fought like tigers to defend
the gateway of their homeland
and far from sweeping across holland to
aid the hard-pressed paratroops the
tanks of the second army's 30 court were
reduced to a crawl by the combination of
unsuitable terrain and determined
opposition
and this is going to finish out this
section of the book defeat was absolute
and terrible
short on everything but courage
the men of first airborne division held
on
until their numbers had been reduced
from 1005 to less than a quarter of that
figure
total allied losses and killed wounded
and missing
exceeded
thousand
some five thousand more than those who
became casualties on d-day
so there you have it defeat was absolute
and terrible
and that despite the fact that for the
beginning of this section sheer nifty
initiative quickness of mind fortitude
and self selfless heroism the conduct of
those who actually fought the battle has
never been surpassed
and and this you want to talk about
disturbing
uh
field marshall montgomery described the
mission as a 90
success
that's that's how he presented it
i think to be clear if i understand in
the aftermath in the aftermath of
everything that happened he considered
it yeah he reported considered
told people right
that this was a 90
success
um actually
there's a little quote in there i gotta
read based on that
there's this
the the he so he says this is a 90
success
and um there's a
prince bernard of the netherlands
said
my country can never again afford the
luxury of a montgomery success yeah
so that's what we've got um
it's insane
it's weird how you and i are the loss
for words over and over and over again
if you know if you're listening to this
and you've got some free time i think i
mentioned it last time we're talking
about some of the characters but bannon
brothers covers this and and market
garden from the american
um you know uh
airborne troopers and nrm
there's a cool
replaying and retelling of this and what
we saw in the combination but this is
revealed there it's it's it's very well
done
but it does not it does not
um expose the depths of the why behind
it it looks at looks like it looks at it
from a tactical point of view and it's
it's very good to see it's really you
should watch it it's
banner brothers is awesome but this
takes it and reveals it on a level
that that for me the reason i can't i
don't know what to say it's really hard
to just it's
this is this is 1944.
yeah that we aren't new we we are not
we're experiencing combat yes
when d-day is behind us
like this isn't figuring out hey how do
we get our footing here things are not
going all this isn't singapore this
isn't pearl harbor this isn't the
invasion of poland and this isn't even
the battle of britain this is 1944.
it's it's it's crazy yeah
you know you can see uh
i guess the british the british generals
but they they have a different little
character that they play you know when
they get up and they need to convince
people you can see like monty right you
know
getting up well gents it's a rough fight
but we've got 90 success right you know
you can like
they're doing a different thing but it's
the same it's a different accent
but it's the same
chest out
furled eyebrows
a little bit more
a little bit more haughty from the brits
from montgomery
but he's playing that same role
and you got to ask yourself why does
this happen why why is this happening
why are we going through
these historical examples
it's not from technology it's not from
lack of fighting spirit
it's not the terrain
that's bad leadership
and where does this bad leadership come
from where is it rooted well it is
rooted in the psychological
the psychological
minds
of these leaders and there's plenty of
great ones and we're not talking about
them on this podcast
we're talking about the psychopaths
and we will dive into that
on the next
podcasts
until then echo charles yes sir um you
know we're we're trying to not be
psychopathic types of leaders
we're trying to be better than that
we're trying to be better in all ways
you know
yeah got any recommendations for us how
to get better we're trying
not to have monumental complacency
that's definitely we're trying not to do
that i think that was a thing yeah
so yeah let's not do that how about that
okay well let's start with ourselves
right
you start with yourself
i'm not gonna
put your oxygen mask on before my own
okay
otherwise i cannot breathe and then i
cannot you know
function well i i guess technically
speaking if i was in charge of a group
of soldiers yes and i was
uh i had gout
i was overweight yeah
i was unhealthy
i was mentally unstable
yes i don't think i'm gonna do a good
job leading my soldiers it's gonna be
very hard it's gonna be difficult yeah
so
let's to your point let's make sure
we got our together yes sir i agree
and yeah here's some ways to do it look
we're working out we're reading we're
reading we're definitely reading we're
listening
oh that's what i do
yeah i listen work out and read yeah i
work out and i listen you know and i'll
read here and there either way
when we work out we do things we got to
put our bodies through little something
so they can adapt to be ready for a big
something hopefully hopefully hopefully
okay on this path we're going to take
some beatings it's okay we got some
supplementation okay let's talk about
energy drinks first
energy drinks the good energy drinks
actually now i think nowadays when we
talk about energy drinks we're not even
talking about the bad ones anymore yeah
well unless we indicate so we need to
make sure that we tell people that when
we talk about energy drinks we're
talking about a certain type of energy
drink that's good for you in all aspects
that's what i'm saying exactly okay
there are energies that are horrible for
you yes sir but now for not for now from
now on we're going to indicate that
we're talking about that kind either
either way i got you
okay giaco discipline go
energy drinks if you don't know that's
the that's a healthy energy drink got a
little bit of caffeine in that one 95
milligrams like a cup of coffee yes sir
um a bunch of other healthy stuff
it's an energy drink that is literally
healthy for you tropics vitamins boom
there you go yeah it's basically
everything that you've caught that you
come to energy drinks for without the
the backside what it called tab you got
to pay with your health have you ever do
you like the taste of any fast food
well you know depends on uh like and let
me clear the path for you let me clear
the path for you
you if you bring me to a wendy's which i
used to work at i'm going ham in wendy's
right i understand like i would i really
enjoy the taste of wendy's probably two
years ago
i think one of my kids went and got uh
mcdonald's you familiar with this place
i i hear things yeah
i had a couple fries
and let's face it dude i mean these
things are engineered
by
doctors
and physicists and chemists to satisfy
your
your taste buds yeah and your dopamine
is firing right all this stuff is going
on
so now imagine this all that goodness
imagine if you had all that goodness and
there was zero downside
right
well you know it's funny i had this
mental exercise because that's what you
get with with with the go yeah you get
all that you get all that goodness you
get all that goodness everything's no
doubt before yeah exactly
you just go
just go ham
you literally drink four of them
because you're not gonna sleep tonight
no i actually i probably am well maybe i
don't know either way
i signed up for all that same thing yeah
yeah the mcdonald's thing i talked to my
kids before they go to bed wendy's
burger king uh what's your go-to well i
don't know i haven't legitimately had
fast food
in years like i haven't okay like i had
a few fries
wait a second chick-fil-a
well during wrestling he's during
wrestlemania
is not
like as greasy let's face okay so we
talked about this actually briefly why i
went when i was on my work way to greg
jane's house
and
i i had some mcdonald's straight up and
i went kind of hard too i didn't eat
anything all day it was weak it was very
very weak uh oh that's the time you got
like taunted by it was right on the side
of the road right on the side like
literally like
it was almost easier to get to great
trains house if you went through the
mcdonald's drive-through
this is what you convinced yourself that
is what it felt like yes well you know
there's that wendy's right by victory
mma in fitness yeah oh yeah that's
another one that's another one but i
fell for the trap of wendy's one time i
told you this i think i told you this
where after training i was like i was in
the mood for wendy's for like
48 hours and i was like okay man look
there's the wendy's on the way to
training i'm like there's the wendy's
today's the day i can't deal with this
feeling anymore i go train like kind of
hard
after training i go boom right into the
wendy's right out of the wendy's drive
through boom go eat it and i felt
completely like afterwards oh
completely after training wendy's boy it
like it jams you up oh yeah you
shouldn't do that from then on wendy's
is easier to resist check this out
imagine if you could go to wendy's and
you ate it and it was delicious and made
you feel great yeah yeah help you
recover that's what this drink is yeah
that's what this drink is oh it's a
miracle
it's a miracle with a miracle it's a
that you can have all upside and no
downside that's a miracle right am i
wrong you were not am i wrong dude
you're correct actually all right well
so there you go you might want to try
some of that yeah yeah so now everyone's
fired up i get it a similar vein molk
yeah similar vein molk yeah because the
same thing you're fired up to have
something that tastes really good you're
fired up for a milkshake
yeah but you know you if you go gut bomb
a milkshake bro like you feel like
insulin coming out of your eyes it's a
disaster
but you go to mulk yeah easy money your
your insulin level is freaking
flat-lined yeah yeah there's no spike
sweetened with monk fruit
no no reason to go kill yourself no
reason if you drink poison no no reason
to drink poison it's another miracle
it's true so
uh
brought to you by chocolate fuel
while you're at it take care of your
joints you got joint warfare super kill
oil why you got to take care of your
immunity cold war
and vitamin d3 sometimes you don't get
out in the sun as much as we need to
that's bad you know that is bad but the
the sun
provides vitamin d but if you don't get
it from the sun boom vitamin d3 you
don't have to go to out in the sun if
you don't want to do my dog goes out in
in my uh on a lounge chair like a chair
what is it called um
like a deck chair
he just goes out there and he just gets
vitamin d all he goes sunbathing
well yeah so he might not need this but
for those of us who may not hit the sun
as often as your dog or whatever oh yeah
vitamin d3 all good all right
where are we to get these miracles
[Music]
yep jogglefield.com
at the vitamin shop vitamin shop
also for the energy drinks
yeah you know what we're working on
ready to drink mulk
so you just roll it and you just pull it
off the shelf and you're slamming a
milkshake that's good for you oh yeah
this is like another miracle
dishing up miracles it's good
but yeah so yeah also you can get a
subscription to this stuff if you don't
know that you get free shipping and you
get it you're gonna remember to order it
because sometimes when you order it
takes one two three four i don't know
however i don't know where you live so i
don't know how long it's gonna take to
get your house but sometimes there will
be that lag time that you don't want
especially with the joint stuff actually
pretty much with all the stuff so you
get on the subscription boom you get it
reliably boom boom free shipping by the
way
also
origin usa oh yeah you're going to want
to get on that yep you want some
american-made stuff especially the denim
and the boots and then again i guess you
know it depends on what you like what
you're into well denim and boots aren't
going to do you any good if you're
looking to train jiu jitsu yep but boom
we got some key uh geez american made
the rifgi by the way women talking about
the roof key but that's one that's like
depends on who you are but you can sleep
in that thing like pajamas for sure if
we made a long one like a long jacket
you could be straight up in a robe
right you'd be straight up in
yeah i might even exercise my right to
wear that robe too from time to time it
looks good
but yeah a lot of good stuff all made in
america yeah like from from the
beginnings of the materials probably
even from the thoughts of the beginnings
of the materials all made in america so
yeah you want to support american
economy yes one of the ways you want and
you do want to support the american
economy yes sir you do want to do that
yeah it's true again origin usa.com if
you like something on there yeah get
something you support uh you support a
lot actually
also speeding up speaking of supporting
a lot chocolate stores called jocko
store i'm gonna represent support
yourself support the cause support the
path
represented the path get a shirt get a
jacket get a hat something like this we
have a subscription situation too called
the shirt locker
if you're interested in creative
artistic yet
representative designs sherlockers for
you
good feedback on that one i'm telling
you but yeah look into that one
chocolate store if you're subscribing to
stuff subscribe to this podcast
subscribe to jocko unraveling with daryl
cooper grounded podcast warrior kid
podcast also you can subscribe is that
the right word for the underground
yes
jockowunderground.com you can subscribe
sure but more importantly you can
support
a methodology that we can turn to should
there be
problems what kind of problems banning
shadow banning
censorship
those kind of things we're we're not
saying that that's gonna happen but what
kind of preparation would it be if we
didn't have a contingency
scenario so we got that uh
jacounderground.com it cost 8.18 cents a
month if you want to be a part of that
we do another little podcast called jaco
underground where we talk about
different topics we answer your
questions we bring up some adjacent
things
compliment
complex complementary
what's the word that would contemplate
contemplate concentration
yeah
no contemplative
if okay thoughts of jocko's that's what
i've kind of discerned from it you'd be
like i was thinking about this
and you're like this is this gives me a
little outlet yeah yeah outlet for a
little deeper dive into various subjects
little discussions yeah yeah
some good q a on that one too
so there you go we also have a youtube
channel where we put up the videos of
this podcast we've been putting up the
unraveling podcast slowly but surely
yeah
maybe some more of those could get up
there yeah if
we are not too busy we're working hard
on that one for sure
uh some uh other clips that echo charles
puts together what do you think dave
what's your favorite uh jocko podcast
youtube channel video
not the one of him talking trash to me
i'm assuming i think the framing one's
my favorite one oh
wait was that on youtube yeah i think so
for sure framing up yeah the framing up
yeah yeah wait do you think it's just on
uh the gram
no no yeah the longer the longer ones
are on youtube yeah you're right you're
right you're right if you want to see so
what's that called behind the scenes
yeah which is basically me talking
yes yeah hard
hard deserved
in many cases you know not always
sometimes go a little too hard maybe
your black guy is deserved i don't know
maybe maybe not
also speaking a youtube uh
uh channels your origin usa
they have a good youtube channel origin
hd you want to see how the inner
workings of an american factory
resurrect manufacturing by the way you
want to see how that works man that's a
good that's a good outlet american
factories we've got multiple factories
now yeah we're growing yeah we're
bringing back manufacturing to america
yeah
yeah that's a good one also
psychological warfare is an album with
tracks jocko tracks of him telling you
how to get through moments of weakness
these are weaknesses that i
experience literally i experience
i told ya'll make this little
thing
this recording you listen to it boom no
more moment of weakness a moment of
strength really
at the end of the day flipside canvas if
you want something to hang on your wall
that's cool dakota meyer is making it
for you go to flipsidecanvas.com got a
bunch of books you know what they are
final spin look final spin coming out
november 9th
what are you shaking your head at dave
just cannot wait for it to come out i'm
just
it's freaking it's rad um super stoked
on it and looking forward to that coming
out then everything else you know
leadership strategy and tactics code
evaluation protocol discipline equals
freedom field manual way the warrior kid
one two three and four
mikey and the dragons
about faced by hackworth
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership echelon front is our
leadership consultancy
we solve problems through leadership
that's what we do leadership is the
solution
go to echelonfront.com if you want
details on that we have live events we
also have an online training academy
because leadership isn't something you
learn in one shot
it's something you have to work on just
like going to the gym just like jiu
jitsu
so
there's a bunch of courses on there you
can take there's live sessions that
we're doing two three times a week where
if you want to ask me a question you can
ask me if you want to ask dave a
question you can ask dave
go to extremeownership.com if you want
to get involved in that and also if you
want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star family check
out mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization helping out in so
many different ways if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my repetitious
reciting
or you need more of echoes unattached
assertions or dave's exploratory
explanations
[Music]
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on the gram on facebook dave is that
david r burke echo is at echo charles
and i'm at jacqueline and thanks to
everyone out there in the armed services
who step up and execute and get the job
done even when leadership is lacking
and also thanks to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics
emt's dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service and all
first responders thank you for standing
duty here on the home front and keeping
us all safe and everyone else out there
there's a common theme in this book
that like i said it's really not in this
book and that is a failure to detach
and as we read these blunders and errors
and catastrophes it's so easy to see
these mistakes being made
but they're not obvious to the people
that are caught up in making these
mistakes
they can't see the tactical errors they
can't see their emotions they can't see
their ego
and it wrecks them
and it causes these disasters so don't
allow that to happen to you
the worst mistakes we make are the ones
we don't see
and we don't see them because we're too
close so step back
detach
see what you're supposed to see and
that will allow you to do what you are
supposed to do
and until next time this is dave and
echo and jocko
out